[Música]
llegó el día en que descubras tu
verdadero poder
sentía que algo le faltaba a mi vida era
como esa sensación de estar incompleto y
mi carrera estaba en un punto en el que
a veces tenía proyectas a sus asas donde
me pagaban su bien y de repente me
pasaba un ratote sin chamba y mi vida
no estaba mal pero no era lo que yo
quería porque que va de protagonizar una
película de steven spielberg y ser
superhéroe de marvel a hacer la rosa de
guadalupe y yo decía ay si encuentro esa
cosita que está haciendo falta con ese
clic que haga voy a poder llegar al
éxito que estoy buscando
yo necesitaba respuestas y qué hacemos
cuando no sabemos qué hacer
vamos a que lo lean las cartas vamos a
que nos lean las cartas y entonces fui
con un chavo y pues ya sabe muy
espiritual la onda los inciensos y todo
vestido de blanco y me dice
es que tienes mucha envidia a tu
alrededor la luz que genera se es tan
grande que puedes a la gente le da
envidia y en el medio en el que tú estás
pues no estás más expuesto todavía pero
no te preocupes te voy a hacer una
limpia y estás a poner está medallita y
todo bien y yo no le va a pues órale me
pongo ya la limpia chaqueta la ramita
hasta la cosa
un hombre salida y
limpio inmaculado libre de envidias y
dije ahora sí ya estoy listo para mi
éxito
y pasa un mes y dos y tres y spielberg
sigue sin hablarme
aquí está faltando algo siento que no
termine como de liberar algo no no se
necesita
algo más poderoso que puede ser que
puede ser que puede ser
ayahuasca claro ayahuasca a todos los
amigos que le han hecho me han dicho que
te transforma la vida y que ibas y eso
es lo que necesito y busque a un chamán
de ayahuasca pero primero no sé si sepa
lo que la ayahuasca la ayahuasca
contiene una sustancia que se llama dmt
que es una sustancia que nosotros
naturalmente producimos solo en dos
momentos de nuestra vida cuando nacemos
y cuando nos morimos así de poderosa es
y la ayahuasca es un madrazo de esto
entonces bueno fui busque un chamán
llegué a las ceremonias sin saber en qué
me estaba metiendo pero ello estaba
listo para que algo más me ayudara a
encontrar ese éxito que estaba buscando
y en mi ceremonia vi de tu ojo
empezó muy bonito con fractales y veía
colores y decía guau así se siente el
morado no manches eso está padrísimo y
de repente ya estaba como en una choza
de nativos americanos y de repente
estaban en las pirámides de egipto y así
un viaje soteno me convertí en animales
y de repente
se abre el piso y empiezan a salir
miles y miles y miles de demonios que
hacen una montaña entre ellos a tipos y
me llegaban a las piernas y yo desde
niño le tenía mucho miedo a los demonios
porque me educaron católico y pues ahí
hay muchas de esas entonces tuve y estos
demonios que se me preparan de escalada
y por primera vez me sentí en completa
paz de estar en control de la situación
y tranquilamente hacia point y me
quitaba los demonios y volvían a hacer
la montaña y se me colgaban
y me los volvía a quitar
ese fue el primer momento de
empoderamiento
pasamos nuestra vida evadiendo nuestros
miedos sin darnos cuenta que eso es lo
que los hace más fuertes y en el momento
en el que para nos vemos frente a frente
esos miedos pierden fuerza y recuperamos
nuestro verdadero poder
y ya después en ceremonia se abrió el
cielo y bajaron los ángeles y yo estaba
muy bonito y todo mucho luz mucha paz y
dije si yo me quedo sin pedos y el
chamán bernardo yo sí o que ya y abría
los ojos otra vez no y cerraba los ojos
y me volvía a ir bernardo yo que ya me
quedo aquí me quedó muy bien ese fue el
primer acercamiento que tuve a la magia
que existe dentro de todos nosotros
dije esto si me transformo siento que
hay un cambio en mí pues ya ahora sí
vamos a esperar esa llamada del buen y
steven spielberg
y quien seguía sin llamar mi buen amigo
escribí y dije no esto no está
funcionando aquí me faltó algo sabes que
creo que necesito otra ya busquets a
otra y aquí está otra y aguas quita
venga como no fui a otra ceremonia con
el mismo chamán y en esta ocasión me la
pasé
terrible estuve con ansiedad todo el
tiempo con miedo y terminando dije no
creo creo que esto no se va a resolver
por aquí lo dejo poner por la paz
pero algo ya se había plantado y
empezaba a ver el mundo diferente no
estaba tan consciente de ello no lo
comprendía al 100% pero algo ya se había
empezado a gestionar
seguí con mi vida pues la parte laboral
muy normal no castings este de repente
proyectos de repente no y de repente vi
casting en chicago
para el protagonista de la próxima
película de steven spielberg y esta
película se llama west side story que
aparte es una obra que yo hice hace años
y en esta obra hay un personaje que se
llama bernardo como yo dije way este es
mi estrés mío este bueno me va a decir
que no compre un vuelo me fui a chicago
llega la audición la hago toda la cosa y
me dicen
bernardo
nos gusta este mucho
te queremos volver a ver el viernes para
un callback
no entonces pues ya llegó el viernes a
nicole va todo bien haga mi callback y
me dicen bien perfecto les gustó
muchísimo regreso a mexico y pues ahora
si yo ya pegado el teléfono no esperando
la llamada y pasaba el tiempo y no
llegaba y no llegaba y en eso se acerca
a un amigo mío que vengo de hace muchos
años y me dice oye fíjate que ahora
estoy haciendo ceremonias con buffet al
varios el buffet al varios es el sapito
de sonora que es una versión de emt y yo
dije
órale para que termine de amarrar esto
no fui a la ceremonia la primera de
muchas porque después empecé a colaborar
mucho con este amigo y
fue
una conexión profunda con el universo
con la madre tierra yo podía sentir los
árboles y fue una expansión enorme
enorme enorme de amor que cuando vives
eso
dices quiero esto por el resto de mi
vida
pero de nuestra vida es un caminito que
a veces damos pasitos para adelante y
pasitos para atrás y pues a mi el día a
día el enrollarme pues en los miedos no
de muy aveces no tengo dinero el ego de
no quedar a veces en proyectos y decir
por qué que pasaba que no sé qué y no
enfocar esto que ya había descubierto
regrese al bernardo que buscaba
respuestas en todos lados
y aquí es donde entra una personita que
me dice
y habrá una semana
y me dijo esto esto y esto y esto y yo
no le había dicho nada no me conocía yo
dije no podemos dando la mediana vamos
estás y vas a ver qué onda llegué con
esta semana y me dice
lo que pasa es que te hicieron un
trabajo con la santa muerte y por eso
estás bloqueado no te está haciendo
tanto daño porque pues te energía es muy
fuerte pero si te está bloqueando yo no
pues vamos a hacer algo no ok pues vamos
a hacerte una limpia me dice ella dio
perfecto va muy bien te vas a parar en
este círculo de fuego de fuego fuego
literal fuego flameante fuego así y vas
a extender los brazos y cerrar los ojos
y ahí me tienen
y empieza a escuchar
como me pasan cuchillos por todo el
cuerpo y empiezan a hacer unas oraciones
en quién sabe qué idioma y yo nada más
decía ay diosito por favor que no me
estén metiendo el chamuco y yo aquí sí y
limpien mi tiempo y estamos haciendo que
madre terminal a la limpia y me dice la
chamana
multipista relajada tú crees esto cristo
y en medio del fuego con la posibilidad
de morir quemado con los cuchillos y
agradezco profundamente
adherido a esa ceremonia porque saliendo
de ahí
descubrir la respuesta que busco no está
aquí afuera
y aprendí algo muy hermoso que fue todas
esas experiencias místicas mágicas que
tuve claro que me sirvieron por supuesto
pero no para que resolvieran mi vida
como una pócima mágica que muchas veces
nos acercamos a estas cosas esperando
eso que algo no lo resuelva no me sirvió
para encontrar esa fuente profunda de
amor para descubrir quién soy realmente
independientemente de la profesión que
elegí de las metas que me puse de la
idea de éxito que elegí que fuera mi
verdad
y cuando descubres esto
tienes ya la conciencia de decir ok todo
esto que he vivido en mi vida porque
todas las cosas que vivimos en nuestra
vida tienen que ver con nosotros
nada externo está haciendo que nos
sucedan cosas absolutamente todo tiene
que ver con nosotros con las
experiencias pasadas que tenemos que no
hemos procesado emociones que hemos
liberado heridas que no hemos ganado y
cuando descubres esto y te haces
consciente entonces dices ah yo tengo la
capacidad de convertir mi vida en lo que
quiero y cuando ves esto no hay nada
externo que pueda quitártelo y empiezas
a ser muchísimo más consciente en las
cosas que haces las frases que te dices
en que cada energía que pongas en tus
emociones te puede llevar hacia adelante
o te puede frenar de llegar a tu máximo
potencial
la espiritualidad no es rezarle a un ser
superior y esperar que me lleguen sus
bendiciones o que resuelva mi vida la
espiritualidad chingona es encontrar ese
ser superior dentro de ti que eres tú
mismo en plena conciencia para que
cuando sucedan todas estas cosas en tu
vida sepas de qué experiencias del
pasado vienen y tomes la decisión sigue
enganchando me a esto
o lo procesó lo trabajo lo suelto y doy
un paso adelante en mi evolución
hasta el día
spielberg no me hablado los de marvel
tampoco
pero ese clic dentro de mi safe y
descubrí que mi valor no está en las
metas que voy logrando o las que no he
logrado mi valor está en la más pura
esencia de ser simplemente yo
y cuando eliges vivir así descubres tu
verdadero poder
gracias
[Aplausos]